what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so normally we would do dark nights
not dark nights metal we would do Batman
the the white night which we might still
do but this is better so actually comics
1000 this is a huge deal my closing guys
who don't know Action Comics 1000 is a
massive landmark like it is the first
comic book to go through single issues
in numerical order and reach a thousand
issues like it's this is this is massive
and it's huge and it really is a big
time for celebration but one thing I
also want to talk about here is I want
to talk about a guy named Curt Swan
those of you guys who don't know between
Superman number 51 in 1948 running all
the way up to whatever happened to the
man of tomorrow in 1986 Curt Swan was
the Superman artist but he was the guy
who drew him whether it was covers
whether it was inside stories other
people did occasionally but like Curt
Swan is like the Superman artist so if
you guys ever happen to be at a at a you
know anywhere in the chemical community
or you're at a store or movie or
something like that and people talk
about like the important contributions
of Curt Swan or they name-dropping or
something like that then you'll know
what that means
he is the superman artist but again this
is just like this is this is awesome i
mean that the cool thing about actually
how much 1,000 is this not just like a
giant story right like it's actually a
whole bunch of small stories with
different writers and artists paying
their tribute to superman in like
various ways because one thing to bear
in mind is that a lot of people who were
writing and drawing comic books least a
lot of the older crowd grew up with
comics and there are some members of the
newer crowd who have others kind of
right for comics because they have a
background in other forms of media or
the forms of print media or digital
media but in a lot of ways like a lot of
these people grew up with Superman
comics Superman has almost this thing
where like you're born knowing who
Superman is you know it's like it's like
gene knowledge you know gene base
knowledge we just inherently know who
Superman is but initially this this
first real mini story cuz I think what
we're gonna do depending on how this
goes we might go through and just start
covering like all these small stories
over the course of however long it takes
for us to finish him but like this
initial one by Dan Jergens basically
picks up with Superman fighting against
a race called the Coons and and it's
kind of cool you know the cons I guess
you know khu nds no idea how you
pronounce that but fighting off against
like this race of this race of guys who
were you know one of the many races that
tries to like launch an invasion of
Earth periodically and it's kind of
funny because when you look at this this
is actually there's a really really cool
story and I can reverse from there's a
really interesting story that opens up
with either it's Superman or Superboy
whose
pulling a chain of planets out of a
dying galaxy it was just an insane
Display of power from the old Silver Age
comics but like it just opened up with
him doing that and that's this this is
kind of like a small little tribute to
that I mean I don't know if that's dan
Jergens intention but it's kind of how
it comes across but this whole thing is
basically a celebration for Superman and
Lois Lane and Jonathan cannon of course
at this particular celebration waiting
for Clark to show up which he ultimately
does the funny thing here is that Clark
doesn't want to be there like Superman
doesn't actually want to be there and
that's kind of the cool thing one of the
big aspects of the Superman character is
that there's two types we have the new
52 reboot it's Superman from 2011 and
then we have Superman and there are two
distinctly different versions the the
2011 new 52 version was designed to be
younger he was designed to be a guy who
had basically just come into the role of
being Superman learning about what it is
that he can do and he can do he already
had a strong understanding of his powers
but taking those powers and applying
them to a superhero element and being in
a city where people call for help and
recognizing that you can't be everywhere
at once that was a core part of his
character the issue with this is that
Superman's not Batman he's not Aquaman
he's not Wonder Woman he's not the Green
Lantern Superman is Superman and so when
people read his stories what they expect
to see is a guy who for all intents and
purposes seems to have it all figured
out and that's what we didn't get in
2011 and that's why a lot of like the
older fanbase the classic fanbase for
classic stories didn't really take to
that new version of Superman new fans
did they were just kinda like hey this
is cool like I like this new younger
version of Superman it was a kind of a
kind of battle back and forth between
the two but at the end of the day
Superman's not one of those characters
where you can walk the middle line you
can't really like split the difference
right you can't you can't have like new
52 flash and the classic flash existing
in the comic at the same time he can't
have that you could only have classic
Superman or the new 52 Superman because
he's so iconic and so DC ultimately
decided to go with the classic Superman
which works because he's the guy that
that like all other heroes look up to
and that's what's going on here is this
massive celebration Clark doesn't
necessarily want to be there because
he's just kind of like look I should be
out dealing with super villains I
appreciate what everybody's doing you
shouldn't really like praise me for
doing what it's basically my
responsibility to do and that's the way
classic Superman was always written and
so because of this when he initially
shows up he's kind of hesitant but of
course Lois Lane calls him by his full
name Clark Joseph Kent so that means
he's in trouble anyway at the end of the
day she's is kinda like look just spare
a minute like
you've got the whole world to protect
and that's fine but you're not the only
superhero on earth you got the entirety
of the Justice League
let them be superheroes this is your day
and it's cool because it was like she
rips her shirt open there's a Superman
symbol and Jonathan's like she's been
waiting all day to do that which
admittedly if I were in the DC Universe
I would do it all the time like I would
I would interplay sit like I would go
into stores and just be like BAM
Superman like I would do that all the
time like I think it'd be amazing but
but the cool thing is that people start
going through and they start offering
these testimonials now here's the
important thing to bear in mind here
this is why this is so awesome is
because there's three stories that we
get there's like well really about three
or four stories that we get here and
each one of the stories highlights
things in a different capacity this is a
story where there were basically this
this you know oceanic attack and tunnels
were flooded and people were essentially
doomed Superman showed up and he
basically saved the day pull this you
know train out of the tunnels and
everybody was safe from there it jumps
into this story of like a firefighter
and this talks about how like these
people's lives were impacted by the
actions of Superman then even if
Superman was like the hero they counted
on Superman inspired them to try to
become heroes themselves and in this
instance this this you know this chief
firefighter had gone back into a burning
building under the under the hopes of
like rescuing one of the people who were
there because that's what Superman would
do now he would have succumb to the
flames I mean he doesn't have any other
durability or any that stuff of Superman
but Superman showed up and saved him but
it's cool because his stance was this is
what Superman would have done and so I
should do that even if it means I'll die
even if it means I could die in this
whole thing you know and and this child
might die with me it's my responsibility
to get in there and to save this kid
from there we took up with Maggie Sawyer
who's basically kind of like part of the
metropolis special Crimes Unit but she
essentially talked about how like
Superman shown up on various occasions
to you know assists her team and like
these various missions with hostages and
different things like that each one of
these things it's hitting all these
different marks but notice this none of
these stories are about like worldwide
calamities right like you know man I was
sit at home one day and aliens show up
and thank goodness for Superman because
he saved the world because that's not a
personalized contextual thing right like
Superman is saving the world saves
everybody on earth so you know for how
it impacted the a guy in Metropolis it
would impact somebody in Gotham the same
way it would impact people all the same
way because it was a global threat but
it provides more of a personal touch
individual person has a story that's
unique to them and that's the basis
behind this that's the whole point is to
tell a story where a person was saved by
Superman in a way that they weren't
saved by you know that nobody else was
saved by and this was kind of cool for
the the last story that we get actually
comes from this guy and his and is
really really interesting it's got any
mr. Benning and and initially Jonathan's
response is like why are they letting a
criminal talk and of course Superman's
response is stop and listen like listen
to this guy story and what mr. Binney
starts to do is basically talk about how
he fell down into this path of the
criminal life now here's this is kind of
a cool thing whether it was Dan Jergens
intention or not I don't know but this
feels this really seems like a big
tribute to Paul Dini and Alex Ross's
Batman war on crime those you guys
should never read that story it is like
the most beautiful Batman story ever it
is it is amazing but this guy basically
says like he found himself falling down
through like a life of crime because for
him it was easier to be a criminal than
it was to work a legitimate job it was
easier for him to take what didn't
belong to him then to like work for it
and so because of this you know we
started running into like criminal
enterprise after criminal enterprise
being nothing more than just like a
stooge
somebody who just kind of offered a kind
of interference you know in order to
keep Superman from like coming after the
actual criminal threat then on the third
time when he was busted Superman finally
like put in a word for this guy and he
ended up landing like landing a
legitimate job that's what he needed was
the ability to land a job put his skills
to use and find stable employment and
that's the point the sumit kind of makes
to his son he says that's the basis of
why I do what I do the reason why I do
things is because everybody is capable
of becoming better like that's the point
of Superman and that's why these little
mini stories are so cool is because
that's the basis of the Superman
character the basis of Superman is to
always be the thing that everybody can
be like to to basically be one step
ahead of everybody else because he's
leading people that's the idea behind
the Superman mythos in the Superman
character now a background theme has
been going on here his Lois Lane has
been on the phone with with Perry White
her editor over at the Daily Planet and
her normal circumstances we would kind
of write that off and it wouldn't really
matter
but then Perry White takes the stage and
Superman's like you weren't talking to
Perry White who in the world were you
talking to which is kind of funny
because Lois Lane was talking to her
side dude that's not true but like it's
cool because every once in a while
Superman gets these glimpses of like an
invasion force from like these these
cons or whatever they are showing up on
earth
and so he's kind of like look like this
is something that we should attend to
but as soon as he sees it it's not there
anymore and so when Perry White takes
the stage Superman kind of flies off in
the midst of his speech in the middle of
his speech continued to like figure out
what's going on when the Wonder Woman
shows up and this is where it gets
really funny Wonder Woman shows up and
and he's like he's like he's like man
like they're you know we have to go deal
with this thing she's like no no it's
cool we have it and he's like whose
wings she's like well your friends the
Justice League you know he's like but I
saw all these things and she's like well
Lois had this really good idea that like
this invasion fleet was coming you know
like like you knew about it so she knew
about it and so she had Martian
Manhunter
uses telepathy on you so you wouldn't
see them and like everybody also take
care of him so you can enjoy your day
and yeah okay I gotta I'll be honest
like that's ballsy like that's that's
it's amazing it's a genius idea because
I can imagine him just being like super
pissed off just be like really this is
what you do Lois you tricked me you
trick your husband you know but it is it
is cool because what is up happening is
this is basically a day for him to
actually celebrate and that's what is
this cool this moment right here
you know what everybody's like cheering
his name and all that kind of stuff this
is a throwback to like 1950s Superman
you know this this is really what this
feels like 1950s
you know 1960 to Silver Age Superman
that's kind of how it feels you know
it's one of those things worse like yes
the story's over Superman one and
everyone cheers for him now because he's
Superman like it's it's cool now a funny
thing that I was thinking of when I when
I thought about this is you know people
were like you know thank you so much for
Superman for all you've done there's
nothing we can do to repay you and you
know wish we could but this is the best
that we can do but if I were Superman I
would be like oh but you can't repay me
you guys can all give me the money you
have well you can give me all the money
in the city and like that's a great book
that's a great way to repay me like I'll
just take money that you have but that's
why I couldn't be Superman I would be
I'd be I'll be honest man I'd be
terrible as sue okay
I'm curious if you guys were Superman
like if you guys have the power Superman
if you had the power Superman Supergirl
you know if you're if you're a woman you
know what like what would you do like
like would you commit crimes like would
you help people would you just be
selfish because like I would be selfish
I wouldn't really commit crimes
dude I would hit on chicks like that's
what I would do I would just pick women
up like I was just I'd fly them just
like hey what's going on girls I'm
Superman they would be like oh my god
super robbed like hey super robbed can
we go back to your place and have a
party and I'd be like yes we can ladies
and you'll find out why they call me the
Man of Steel like I would be
dude I would I would hit on you I would
hit on chicks that's all I would do but
that's just me
all right that's just me I'm a shameless
human being but I'm curious what you
guys would do if you had the power of
Superman what would you do like I'm
curious to see what some of the answers
are because this is the Internet and god
only knows what you guys are gonna say
but with that being said guys we're
gonna prove this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]